but there are different theories of how
the universe might end we've got a
theory of how the universe started with
the big bang and this period of intense
like you and I are currently well I
don't know we're probably I'm in
Scotland right now so we're probably wow
I don't know I'm in Scott I'm in
Scottsdale Scottsdale oh fine okay
so I was gonna say we're only like a
foot apart which is amazing that it
feels like that but um no we are we are
many thousands of miles apart but
something thousands of miles apart at
the beginning of the universe would now
be billions of light years apart so that
happened at the beginning of the
universe we've got this
insane period of expansion we call it
the big bang and now we want to know
what will happen at the end and I think
that's a different question of the
theory of everything that's like a
theory of everything like what is matter
and how does it interact and what is
dark matter and gravity is like one area
of physics and then cosmology is like
where did we come from where are we
going that is a really fascinating area
of of thought and exploration and
research to me is what's going to happen
to the universe in the end there are all
these theories that it might just kind
of continue on expanding forever there's
my favorite Theory which is that
eventually it'll slow down in its
expansion because the universe right now
is expanding you've probably heard yeah
the universe is expanding but maybe
it'll slow down and come back together
and bounce like it'll come back together
and bounce and have another big bang you
know it may just keep doing that so
that's where I've seen repeating
patterns come into physics on the
biggest scale would be that's my
favorite and then of course there's the
there's like the I don't know like the
cold death of the universe or something
where it just like expands and expands
forever and then eventually there's no
stars near us and everything's dark in
the sky and it's very depressing so
yeah yeah exactly like when my brain
goes
there's no end it goes for infinity and
then I'm like but there has to be an end
but there's not and what is it and I
know I know and that's where you've I
mean even if there was like a black hole
that created a loot even if time bending
creates like sort of like a bubble of a
universe what's beyond that bubble and
are there multiple universes is it a
Multiverse and what's in between the
multiverses I don't know I would love to
know that's one of the most I think this
is like as a physicist that's one of the
most frustrating sort of barriers I get
to mentally where
where if there if we have this bubble of
a universe or something and there are
other universes outside of it
here's the sad fact we will never know
because by definition our universe is
everything that we can contact we can
get light from we can see we can learn
from we can get like data from these
Stars billions of light years away but
if there's anything outside of it by
definition we'll never know about it
so that's where I'm like oh so
frustrating I want to know like when you
reach the limit of what we possibly can
know and you're like but but but why not
let's talk about dimensions then I mean
I want to talk about quantum
entanglement
let's get into Dimensions so we have
sort of our our reality that we know of
that we can touch and feel this third
dimension which explain dimensions and
then how many we have
actually there there's a video I
recently made about this and I think
this is a probably a fun angle to talk
about Dimensions so have you ever heard
of um time crystals I have not but I was
watching that video
but I didn't get it I didn't completely
get it I was like yeah I'm very curious
about crystals because there's theories
that crystals kind of record information
and isn't there I mean things at the
subatomic level are crystalline and
structure is that yeah yeah yeah things
at the at the atomic level and the
molecular level are crystalline and what
that means in a physical sense is that
uh there's this repeating pattern so
you'll look at
there it is again yes
the moment you've been waiting for it
we only have 57 minutes to figure out
the Theory of Everything
it's going to involve fractals crystals
uh black holes dark matter and basically
when we unite the 13 crystal skulls
Thanos is Crystal
um fist yes I mean I have a lot to tell
you was there was a time Crystal on the
other fist uh but no what is a Time
Crystal uh so so crystals are this this
uh structure
um this sort of material that has a
repeating pattern so if you look with a
very very strong microscope at a diamond
uh you'll see this repeating pattern of
carbon well I think I remember seeing
that when in the video it's basically
like a grid structure exactly yeah and
there are bonds at the at the grid
points there are bonds yeah and there
are there are molecules between so
you'll get carbon and then with
different types of crystals like
tanzanite and rubies and you'll you'll
have different kinds of like silicone
and
um and nitrogen and other types of
things that actually change the color so
when you add silicone instead of a more
carbon than you get a green diamond or
something so when you with this
repeating pattern of of
atoms or of molecules you get a
crystalline structure that's a repeating
pattern in space and so
um what I asked my editor who I was
talking to in that video was how many
dimensions are there like how many do
you know of I kind of am very into this
sort of spiritual woo-woo world as well
yeah I'm pretty sure I think they say 11
or 12 dimensions a human experiential
perspective sure but like from a physics
perspective is going to be such a
different answer so the dimensions from
a physics perspective the three
dimensions of space there are three
there's you know forward backward up and
down and side to side but there's
actually a fourth dimension of space
time so the fourth dimension is time and
so a professor a Nobel Laureate at MIT
was like what what if just bear with me
what if we had repeating structures in
time
and that's where he lost me but he
explained it as like you imagine this
this very small system that just flips
to a different state and then it flips
back and then it flips like imagine I
don't know maybe imagine a ring on your
finger and the the gem just flips to the
bottom and then it flips back to the top
and it flips back to the bottom and it
just does that automatically
periodically in time he was imagining a
system not as big as a ring but on a
really small scale like the atomic scale
as in the repeating atomic structure of
crystals he was imagining this repeating
in time and so I think it was a really
creative way of thinking about
dimensions and thinking about what you
can do in space dimensions but now doing
it in time that's that's a a brief
little sort of mental fun play thought
experiment for what you can do with
Dimensions if you're using uh the time
Dimension and when things flip you
you're saying that that would
essentially be a dimension flip it would
be a flip in the time Dimension so that
repeating structure like silicone carbon
silicone carbon is like a space
repeating pattern but if you're flipping
this state
in the time Crystal then you're flipping
in time because you're going back and
forth and back and forth and that
repetition that repeating so if it's not
silicone are you saying it goes to like
something else yeah the what they ended
up making with a Time Crystal was like
Quantum atom they were the electrons
inside of a quantum computer so nothing
to do with silicone atoms nothing to do
with a ring flipping up and down it's
something like we would never even be
able to see it it's so small and
complicated but they would consider a
Time Crystal because it's this kind of
system like a ring flipping up and down
that repeats in time repetition in time
and they called that a climb Crystal it
keeps going exactly okay so it's not
just it's just naturally repeating in a
cycle yeah and it and and why it was so
special is that you sort of it doesn't
take any energy to do that
so this is like this was one of the
another question people love to ask me
all the time
um is whether we can make a perpetual
motion machine where like you you're
like okay but what if you could uh have
a a solar panel on top of your car and
you shine a flashlight on it
from the car and it'll just keep going
and power I'm like okay but the energy
has to come from somewhere it has to
come from inside of the battery so it it
it's not perpetual motion because
they're like but no but you connect the
solar panel back into the the flashlight
too and I'm like great idea but
yeah yeah there's gonna be losses along
the way and eventually the system will
die it just will no matter what you do
it will die no matter how many times you
ask me in the YouTube comments
so if we're talking about a loop then
and we're talking about time
time bends and that essentially yeah
distance or bending for a long enough
period of time comes back on itself I
would say do we know that no but they're
totally legit theories that
um if you bend space-time enough you
could come back around in a loop how
would you do that we don't know we how
would you like practically do that we
haven't found a way to come back around
which means like would you be
technically
coming back around and meeting up where
you were in time another re another big
question of the universe that we don't
know the answer to yet is why time only
goes in One Direction because in our
experience right you can walk back and
forward you could even reverse your car
on the track typically you don't I'm
guessing and you don't usually go
backwards much you do you don't want to
if you're reversing you're in deep [ __ ]
has that has that ever happened oh sure
like you get in the wrong spot like
something happens on pit lane or
whatever go off the track and are nosed
up to a wall and you need to back up
yeah I mean you need reverse
this is an amazing day that I've gotten
to ask Danica Patrick if she ever if
anyone has to reverse their car you
cannot uh you can go backwards and
forwards in your car you can walk side
to side you can jump up and down but you
can't go backwards in time and we don't
understand why like it doesn't it's kind
of just our everyday experience but this
is where physicists love to be like but
hold on why would you just accept that
there should be a reason why we can only
go forward in time and we don't know
what that reason is yet so I wonder
again if time like we rethink gravity we
rethink time we rethink all of these
things I wonder I was listening to
something the other day and something I
think I don't know if it happens to you
but stuff like Words arrive in my head
and then and I hear them and so
time is a measurement this is what
arrived in my head time is a measurement
of entropy so it's like when you attach
it to just entropy then it it does
connect to moving forward like we think
of time as like there and there and
everywhere and forward and backwards but
maybe time is more just a a measurement
or an explanation for entropy I've never
heard entropy brought into the
definition of time but I I say that
because I think that
um I think it's a really really
interesting and useful way of thinking
of time and especially thinking of
entropy because that Define entropy
though just in case yeah yeah so one of
the other one of the other accepted laws
and in fact the reason why we can't have
a flashlight shining on a card
perpetually on a solar panel on a car
perpetually powering the car
um although you should pitch that too
it's a good idea at NASCAR see what they
say test their belief in uh the thermal
a lot of thermodynamics with a slight
powered cars
be like hear me out but really you're
just testing them
foreign
[Music]